but I love doing shows here I really
really like doing stand up here because
I miss you I miss you I missing you
around I miss you too yeah yeah we were
there that night that I kind of went off
on Dane that was a that was a glorious
night what that was a glorious night
I've we've talked about it last time oh
yeah that one it was when I never uh I
didn't realize that people were
listening to my Twitter
yeah I was kind of like
I'll just go off on him no big deal
nobody's like paying anyone that didn't
listen to the last two days we'll just
we'll just re-cap right it was years ago
it was like a Wednesday or whatever TJ
Miller and I had a spot at the Laugh
Factory and Dane showed up cook and he
did way too long well you left and
that's why that's why I looked at you
and I go I'm not staying for this I'm
leaving and I thought I go and you said
he's got to go after it yeah yeah he did
so much time and he started berating the
audience but I think that was the first
time he'd been up for a long time and he
was pretty upset and now that I'm an
older stand-up comic I I don't really
understand it
the audience I think it's weird to look
at a guy and be like well you don't get
any girls because you're bald you're
just an old bald guy yeah yeah and it's
like that guy is just like what happened
what happened to my night yeah I mean
here the most famous person I've ever
seen just told me I'm an old a horny
oldie ball yeah call back have you seen
callbacks wait have you seen dance have
you seen Dane since then I saw him I saw
him at one point uh because Jay massato
was like you know buddy buddy you have
to get together and we are all children
they are siblings you got to work it out
and he was really interesting and cool
he kind of said you want to talk and we
went in that alley oh cool and it was
really clear that he's like I have so
much hate and so much [__] coming at me
all the time yeah and uh when you're
really famous you'll understand that but
like just don't do that to people you
know what I mean I kind of was like yeah
and it was my bad I mean I didn't I
didn't need to do that and I could have
just left but it really really made me
upset that he was mean to that guy yeah
I remember
so anyway I'm kind of an idiot no you're
not I guess no
um because let me defend you for a
second okay
we as comedians we eat a lot of [__]
right and I know there's hierarchy right
but there are some things that go too
far and I think that's one of them when
somebody goes way too long and ruins the
audience for the people that are after
yeah it's it's just not a cool thing and
that was the other thing is because you
left I was like I have to follow this
and so that made me really upset too and
I've never seen anybody drop in and do
like an hour
except for Chris Rock I've died and I
had to follow him but the audience was
amazing yeah after he got out and what I
learned though ever since then is I say
no no like I I'm still I'm at Club still
yeah and I I have people go hey
so-and-so is going to go before you and
now I just go no
no I I know who I am I'm a name right I
know that I play this club all the time
and this guy that's gonna bump in is
from out of town or he's more famous or
whatever but no that's not gonna happen
and then sometimes they go well it's
gonna happen I just leave
yeah yeah but I'm not let I'm not doing
that anymore I'm not gonna eat it
anymore I'm Who I'm too old for that
I've been around too long you know I I
respect myself I I think I'm a credible
guy and don't push me around no you're
not a credible guy you're an incredible
guy oh oh man you're good with play on
words huh I'm good with loving empath
sympathy and love a friendship
I like it I'm good with friendship Bobby
yeah get used to it
uh yeah the other thing though there is
a
there is an argument for if you're doing
too many sets you're like not thinking
about what you're doing yeah I take away
time from
um regular life which is what you draw
from to but yeah I've always been a a
guy who's just like an extremist I think
that's that has something to do with my
brain damage for sure but it's like
brain damage
no I had an arterial venous malformation
oh yeah yeah I remember yeah